Meine erste Frage ist immer: Wie ist die Lage?
'Genau'
Du hast an deinem Deutsch gearbeitet?
Ja genau. Die Lage ist grossartig. Ich kann mich nicht beschweren.
Nach 2 oder 3 wirklich schwierigen Jahren, wo ich dachte, dass ich so eine Chance, diese nicht noch einmal bekommen werde.
Und jetzt stehe ich hier, mit meinem grossen Erfolg, den ich in 2011 hatte.
Ist es schwierig, einen Schlussstrich zu ziehen und etwas anderes zu machen? Die Band zu verlassen und dein eigenes Ding durchzuziehen?
Es war nicht meine Entscheidung aufzuhoeren. Es waren die Umstaende, die diese Entscheidung für mich getroffen haben.
Das Schoene daran, ein Songwriter, ein Kuenstler zu sein, ist es, dass all diese schwierigen Situationen in die Musik und die Kreativität einfließen.
Ich kam mit Preteesh, dem anderen Mitglied von Mattafix, einfach nicht zurecht.
Wir verstehen uns mittlerweile prima, aber zu der damaligen Zeit war es sehr schwierig.
Wir hatten einen zeitlich begrenzten Vertrag bei der Plattenfirma und wurden dann fallen gelassen. Die schoenen Frauen waren nicht mehr um uns
und dann kamen all diese verrueckten und ernsten Veranstaltungen, die mich in eine Richtung gedraengt haben, wo ich nur noch ein Solo-Album schreiben konnte.
Was denkst du, wenn du in solche Situationen kommst?
Siehst du deine momentane Lage und denkst dir einfach nur: Es ist schlecht! Oder betrachtest du deine Situation im Ganzen und denkst, dass es vielleicht für etwas gut ist, wie es kam?
Ich glaube, das liegt an der Uhrzeit, wo es mich erwischt.
Morgens ist alles deprimierend und ich schaff es nicht, die Fensterlaeden zu oeffnen. Und wenn ich mir dann meine Gitarre schnappe, fange ich an, die Dinge positiver zu betrachten.
Vom Verstand und auf der Oberflaeche betrachtet, sind da sehr viele Selbstzweifel.
Selbst die autoditaktischen Musiker: Bin ich gut genug, um das zu machen? Ist meine Stimme gut genug? Kann ich gut genug spielen? Kann ich diese Songs schreiben, die alles widerspiegeln?
Lag ich falsch? Hat sie mich aus gutem Grund verlassen? All diese Sachen!
Aber darunter, in einem drin, da ist ein Kern aus Stahl und ein starker Glaube an sich selbst.
Und es wird einfacher, nachdem man einige Male in solchen Situationen gewesen ist. Ich denke selbst an den ungluecklichen Tagen,
hat der Songwriter in mir seine Haende gerieben und sich gedacht, dass aus diesem Moment tolle Musik entstehen wird.
Manchmal, wenn ich traurige Momente im Leben habe, denke ich: Es ist traurig, aber ich lebe! Und es ist ein gutes Zeichen, auch solche Momente zu haben.
Auf jeden Fall. Es steckt auch immer etwas Schoenes hinter diesen Momenten. Die Klarheit des Schmerzes, das ist schwierig zu beschreiben.
Und ich weiss nicht, wie ich das ohne die Musik als Ventil geschafft hätte, aber das ist irgendwie ernuechternd.
Mich mit Leuten zu unterhalten, die durch schwierige Zeiten gegangen sind, ist für mich komplett anders geworden. Ich fühle mit ihnen mit, aber auf eine andere Art., es ist als waere ich sie und empfinde all die Gefuehle.
Das war immer toll. Aber was jetzt meine Herausforderung ist, ist zu lernen, Musik zu machen, wenn ich gluecklich bin.
Das koennte vielleicht schwierig werden.
Ja, mal sehen.
Wann kam die Wende in deinem Leben, wo du anfingst, aus deinen Erlebnissen Inspiration zu ziehen?
All die Ursachen kamen schnell nacheinander, wir waren auf Tour mit Mattafix und wir haben uns einfach nicht verstanden, wir haben nicht miteinander geredet. Damit gehen wir sehr offen um.
Ich habe einige Fehler in meiner Beziehung gemacht. Ich war mit einer wunderschoenen Frau verlobt und sie hat mich verlassen und sehr schnell jemand neuen gefunden.
Ich hatte zudem viele familiäre Probleme zu der Zeit und dann wurde EMI aufgekauft und sie entliessen alle, mit denen ich gearbeitet hatte.
Und all diese Dinge passierten in nur 5 oder 6 Monaten.
Aber ich brauchte weitere 2 Jahre, bis mir die Bedeutung davon klar wurde und ich klar genug denken konnte,
um Songs darüber zu schreiben, die wirklich was bedeuten und man dabei nicht dachte: 'Oh mein Gott, das ist bedrueckend!'
'New Age' entstand 2 Jahre nachdem all das passiert ist.  Es war der Ausloeser für all das, aber ich hatte auch einen sehr klaren Verstand in der Zeit, wo ich die meisten der Songs geschrieben habe.
Warst du während du das Album aufgenommen hast, mitten drin oder hast du es erst aufgenommen, als du alles hinter dir gelassen hattest?
Es ist ein konstanter Kreislauf. Nachdem all das passiert ist, flog ich in die Karibik, um mich zu erholen. Da schrieb ich etwa 15 sehr grobe Acoustic Songs.
Wirklich sehr grob. Von guten Songs bis hin zu ziemlich schrecklichen.
Zurück in England begann ich, sie alle mit meinem Keyboard-Player aufzunehmen, in ein oder zwei Takes.
Ich war emotional und körperlich zerstoert. Ich war einige Jahre unterwegs und einige Beziehungen haben mich ausgezehrt.
Es waren sehr rohe Erfahrungen. Und wir haben die Songs aufgenommen und zwei davon schafften es tatsaechlich auf das Album.
'Brotherhood of the Broken' und zum Teil 'Antihero'
Und nach dieser Erfahrung hatte ich mehr Selbstvertrauen an der Gitarre und in meine Stimme.
Ich ging zu Mr. Guy Chambers, ein sehr bekannter Songwriter, und zusammen schrieben wir 'New Age'
Er sagte mir: Ich glaube daran, dass du ein Solo-Kuenstler bist, du hast die Stimme dazu.
Und das aus seinem Mund zu hoeren, von jemandem, der mit den ganz Grossen zusammengearbeitet hat, das war eine unglaubliche Inspirationsquelle für mich.
Dann ging ich nach Amerika. Da habe ich die Hälfte der Aufnahmen gemacht. Und ich hatte kein Geld, kein Label, keine Kontakte.
Ich ging einfach hin, machte mein Ding und ließ mich ueberraschen, was passiert.
Und das kann dir in Amerika schnell passieren: Du kommst mit einer Idee an und die Dinge entwickeln sich sehr schnell.
Ich hab mit einigen der talentiertesten Leute der westlichen Ostkueste gearbeitet.
Wenn ich jetzt zurueckblicke, scheint es mir wie eine Art surreale Geschichte aber waehrend dieser Zeit war ich ganz locker bei dem, was ich gemacht habe.
Du hattest kein Geld in Amerika?
Aber du warst doch vorher mit Mattafix bereits ein Star?!
Ja, aber ich habe alles in das Album reingesteckt.
Und es ist ein Mythos, dass man einen Hit hat und Millionen von Euro in die Hand gedrueckt bekommt.
Nach den Steuerabgaben..
und ich habe mir eine kleine Wohnung in London gekauft, ich habs gerne behaglich, versteh mich nicht falsch,
aber ich habe wirklich alles in das Album gesteckt, was ich hatte.
Ein Rat, den ich jungen Musikern geben wuerde, ist, dass wir als Künstler schuldig sind, wenn es darum geht, die Realitaet dieses Business' falsch darzustellen.
Einen Hit zu haben, bedeutet nicht unbedingt, dass alles okay ist. Es kommt mit Jahren der Arbeit, in denen man sich eine eigene Plattform aufbaum.
Aber manchmal reicht ein Hit aus. 'Last Christmas' zum Beispiel.
Aber nicht in diesem toten Zeitalter, wo das Downloaden, die bevorzugte Option darstellt.
Aber ich denke 'New Age' ist ein Song, wie 'Last Christmas'
Ich denke, 'New Age' ist ein wahrhaftiger Song, mit allem was er braucht: Es hat eine Melodie, eine Struktur, einen guten Saenger. Alles, es ist gut aufgebaut.
Ich denke, es hat das Potenzial, ein Song zu sein, den die Leute in 10 oder 20 Jahren noch kennen werden.
Was ist das Geheimnis?
Wenn ich das wuesste, wuerde ich jeden Tag einen Hit rausbringen. 365 Hits im Jahr.
Fürs Erste moechte ich mit talentierten Leuten arbeiten. So kam ich auch zu Guy.
Zudem will ich mit Leuten arbeiten, die eine einfache Pop-Melodie verstehen, Guy ist klassisch angehaucht, ein sehr versierter Musiker.
Ich liebe die Kombination aus beidem. Wir haben uns nie an einem Akkord verbissen und keine Idee verloren, weil er die musikalische Basis hat.
Der Gesang wurde sehr dicht am Mikrofon aufgenommen, ein deutsches Mikrofon, ein Neumann.
Eine sehr dichte Aufnahme, dadurch klingt es so, als waere ich tatsächlich im Auto, mit dir in der Kueche oder mit dir im Schlafzimmer.
Das ist für mich sehr wichtig.
Und einfach die Geschichte, die Wahrheit, jedes Wort dieses Songs ist die reine Wahrheit.
Als ich es schrieb, hatte ich keine Vorstellung, was Liebe wirklich bedeutet, auch wenn ich es wissen sollte, ich war aelter geworden und  hatte mehr Erfahrungen gesammelt als je zuvor.
Ich sass da und warf meine Haende in die Luft: 'Was auch immer es ist, es ist cool'
Aber ich wusste nicht, wie ich das ändern kann.
Wann wusstets du, dass es ein Hit werden wird?
Auf jeden Fall nicht, als wir ihn geschrieben haben!!! Und ich hasse es, wenn Künstler das sagen.
Wenn du einen Kuenstler sagen hoerst, dass ein Song in 2 oder 3 Stunden geschrieben wurde, findest du es ärgerlich.
Aber tatsaechlich wurde 'New Age' in ein paar Stunden geschrieben. Aber wenn ich zurueckblicke, sehe ich, dass es das Produkt aus Jahren harter Arbeit war, zu dem Punkt zu kommen.
Die Arbeit an dem Song ging schnell und einfach voran und ich dachte, vielleicht wird es die dritte Single.
Aber als ich anfing, ihn vor den Leuten zu spielen, sah wie sie darauf reagierten und meine Plattenfirma Universal mich unter Vertrag nahm
sagten sie deutlich: Es ist ein unglaublich toller Song! Wir denken du bist ein Solo-Kuenstler und das ist unser Plan dafür!
Und diese Leute wissen, wovon sie reden, das war ein tolles Gefühl!
Ich denke als Kuenster hat man einen zumindest teilweise klaren Weg, aber es ist auch wichtig, Leute um sich herum zu haben, die einem gute Ratschlaege geben.
Ich denke, als wir unser Video in Berlin aufgenommen hatten , konnte man es sehen. Du warst nicht so bekannt, wie jetzt und die Leute kamen und haben dir zugehoert.
Und sie waren einfach bezaubert.
Ja, und ich denke, nur in Deutschland gibt es solche Situationen, wo man anfaengt einen Song zu spielen, sich eine Gruppe bildet
und ich hab aufgehoert und gesagt: Koenntet ihr alle dort hinueber gehen, damit wir ein besseres Bild bekommen? Das Licht ist dort besser.
Und jeder ging sofort zu der anderen Seite.
Ich denke sie sind treue Zuschauer und wollen auch wirklich was hoeren.
Aber auch als ich im Auto saß, ich weiß nicht wo, es war irgendwo auf einer wunderschoenen deutschen Strasse, auf der Autobahn,
da kam der Song zwischen zwei Top 5 Songs, die sehr schnell und hart waren. Und dann kam 'New Age' und es klang wie ein frischer Luftzug.
Da hab ich gemerkt, dass es ein grossartiger Song fürs Radio ist.
Ich finde toll, wie du es geschafft hast, mich an den Punkt zu bringen!